no III have a mic no I have this is my
life
yeah but I'm loved oh oh we get your
special talk to a camera what's up I'm
Hannah I'm here post battle with Matthew
Broussard how you feeling what are I'm
really good yeah it's it's nerve-racking
I really enjoy myself I really like your
on show please do not post any of the
talking that I did in the
pre-interview because I really thought I
was gonna win that my joke it's
weird because the jokes I think comics
or battlers like the most of the ones
that go way under the surface but the
ones the crowd likes the most are just
like right there on top drawn I'm really
happy you're here I'm glad to see the
get out surgery went well that's that's
funny because you look like you work the
concierge desk in the sunken place it
sucks because the joke had always got
the biggest response was the get out the
sunken place joke that I had I said it
open with that cuz I knew he was
gonna have one too yeah sure I made a
lot of jokes about your looks and me but
I think you get that a lot yeah Mike
Lawrence had a joke about me that I was
so creepy I would date rape a girl and
leave a sign to headshot on her mantle
or something that was one of my
favorites I like ones that actually I
like ones that make me hurt yeah the way
you say that is like so creepy yeah want
to come back to my dungeon there's been
a lot of fun battling homeless Simpson
nice one you bobblehead of a trump son
I have to ask what is on your arm this
is a quarterback's
wristband at the you know have a
prompter on the episode you could have
just used that but I didn't want to use
the prompter on purpose cuz I don't want
other people seeing my jokes and I have
a lot more great you want to give one to
the camera okay it seems sort of mean to
do but Mike looks like the Greek god of
humidity the guy that dried do I get
another medal for that I got a pretty
big laugh Tony is the Kevin Spacey of
comedy he's creepy closeted and Netflix
has cut all ties with him when he said
that I was closeted I was gonna say
you're right Mike I'm gay and this isn't
roast battle this is an episode of Queer
Eye for the straight guy and here's what
we're going to do to fix you you're the
most sarcastic person this is what
happens when people first meet me they
think I'm being sarcastic and I'm not at
all I'm almost never sarcastic ever at
all
[Applause]